das ist jetzt passiert ändert was geht
ab und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video ja da ich hoffe natürlich
euch jedes gut ich war 14 tage in
österreich ski fahren bin jetzt aber
wieder da und ich habe mir gedacht es
ist eigentlich an der zeit für ein neues
ich teste tik tok live hacks video
allerdings machen wir heute mal was
anderes und zwar geht es heute nicht um
so allgemeine live hacks die man halt
testen kann sondern es geht um es live
acts das ganze ist natürlich ein
bisschen aufwendiger weil man schon so
ein bisschen kommen muss also ich hab
wirklich ganz krasse sachen rausgesucht
ich freue mich auch die euch gleich zu
zeigen ich bin mal gespannt welche davon
funktionieren und welche nicht
übrigens ich habe jetzt zehn metern und
hier von marie solle eine million auf
influenza basis angelehnte symbole
bekriegt kann man es war janne hat er
jedenfalls hatte ich habe so was noch
nie dass das erste mal und die hängen
jetzt so ein bisschen im hintergrund ich
würde sagen wie lange man gar nicht
lange
die tik tok live videos kommen auf jeden
fall richtig gut an und ich hoffe ich
kann in zukunft noch mehr machen
deswegen wenn der boxer überhaupt lassen
denken nach oben da auch natürlich für
weitere essens tik tok live hacks weil
das internet ist voll damit
und man heute unter anderem blauen reist
damit können wir sogar anfangen ich
würde sagen ich bin mal kurz mein handy
und dann zeige ich euch den ersten
[Applaus]
aber scheißegal memory stick kann
seitdem der kamera ja ich habe das
gleiche gedacht eigentlich immer
unheimlich gut dass wir jetzt ein
bisschen hoch mit kannst du wissen
runtermachen mit zwei doch nicht was ist
mit unserem topfit jetzt wieder
vergewaltigt nein leider nicht weiter
einkaufen und habe alle sachen gekauft
ich heute brauche ich wusste gar nicht
dass es das ich dachte eigentlich müsste
powerade kaufen weil es das in
deutschland nicht gibt aber es gibt ist
für 299 auch nur hast du wirst schon mal
getrunken denn in reykjavik nicht
schmeckt es aber das q3 ist also ich mit
gut gemacht aber das kann ich ja nicht
mit reis essen bitte nicht mitreist
vielleicht nicht so gut wer weiß wer
weiß nur der reis da würde ich sagen
dass es kommen natürlich das gateway
hier rein soll ich einfach alles falsch
[Applaus]
und dann habe ich hier ein bischen reis
gekauft ich will aber trotzdem war das
jetzt kocht natürlich nicht alles rein
machen muss das kochen bei reis jahr
natürlich so was für eine frage nicht
bindung also wenn jemand nicht kommen
kann dann ich aber diese tickert live
act sie sind ja eigentlich so einfach
das muss ja jeder können dass wir machen
das hier auf ok dann würde ich sagen wir
warten mal kurz ab und sehen uns gleich
wenn der reis in den topf kommt hmm
stell dir vor du musst dieses gate array
trinken es war ich habe noch eine gute
idee und zwar muss man das ja auch ein
bisschen salzen oder nein nicht reicht
wird nicht gesalzen ein bisschen
wenn ein bisschen okay es kommen ja
schon die ersten szenen gleich kurz ging
ganz schnell eigentlich doch ich mache
jetzt nicht so viel rein weil ich habe
kein fahrrad es mir schmeckt und
natürlich sonst auch verschwendung
mmmh lecker lecker lecker frisch wie das
aussieht vor dreisten stört die ich
machen vorbei
das riecht ganz ganz komisch dieser
kreisleiter der fecht blau diese vom
video die will nicht erzählen dass das
lecker ist oder die macht ja so aber so
blau wie im video ist noch nicht mehr
wir waren noch ein wiesel okay leute ich
zeige euch mal jetzt nicht den reis es
sieht echt lustig aus höhere jemand da
hinten dann präsentiere ich las da okay
man sieht jetzt gleich glaube ich schon
also was jetzt hier im licht so sieht
eigentlich schon echt verrückt aus muss
ich sagen aber ich kann mir wirklich
nicht vorstellen dass das schmeckt dafür
ich doch echt nicht leicht überhaupt
nicht lecker
[Musik]
sowas kann doch wirklich keiner gerne
finden das kann man nicht gleich hin
dass tage gespielt von der auf jeden
fall also es gehört jetzt nicht so zudem
ekligsten sachen die ich je gegessen
habe
aber es ist auf jeden fall nichts geil
ist also dass kein live act oder so das
ist einfach nur verschwendung und eklig
also meinung nach funktioniert das
überhaupt nicht also gut funktionieren
tut der preis wird blau aber das war's
auch schon leute deswegen würde ich hier
auf jeden fall sagen durchgefallen es
ist zwar kein fake aber ich scheiße
deswegen braucht gar nicht nachmachen
dann würde ich sagen gekommen natürlich
sofort zum nächsten ersten tag der
wirklich sehr interessant ist
[Musik]
ohne scheiß weg ins nicht die butter ist
gefroren und man muss sie irgendwie
ausbrüchen kriegen ich fand mich da auch
immer so darüber ab ich bin zwar sehr
kritisch gegenüber eingestellt was jetzt
gerade hier gesehen haben weil ich
glaube dass es das nicht unbedingt
vergleicht hat aber wir können natürlich
mal versuchen nur ganz kurze kleine
währung und zwar wartet auf jeden fall
meinen reaction kanal das ist jetzt
online fachlich euch ganz oben in der
video beschreibung nach oder lassen dann
hör und jetzt machen wir weiter
mit diesem video ich weiß hier eben
einkaufen und habe so eine art ja ich
weiss nicht wert ist das essence perfekt
ein liebste gekauft ist ja so was
ähnliches wie im video
da müssen wir jetzt erstmal hier das
ding abbrechen und jetzt regen sich
wahrscheinlich ganz viele darüber auf
wie das total finden okay wir haben
jetzt ein toastbrot und bisschen an
gepostet dann dieses lippenstift dinge
und feine butter von michael kannst du
auch mehr grip werden die immer im
internet die die belastung auch mal
nicht richtig gut
meine lieblings mutter wirklich niemand
alle dass meine lieblings bis schon ganz
groß
hier haben wir als europas auf und jetzt
muss natürlich die butter hier rein es
ist dann vielleicht am anfang natürlich
den hack aber du musst es ja dann auch
irgendwie mal wieder sauber kriegen das
ist dann ja wieder kein hack oder du
brauchst den anderen hack um es dann
wieder sauber zu machen dann wäre es
natürlich gut na ja also ich drücke das
jetzt mal hier rein funktioniert ganz
gut sagt bis zum boden okay und jetzt
zieht es wieder rauf ja
ok und jetzt ist natürlich ganz klar
wenn ich das mit messer machen würde
wäre schon arbeit
jetzt schauen wir mal ob das hier besser
funktioniert das erste problem ist
direkt kummer man kann es drehen aber es
ist schwer
und jetzt streicht man das hier drauf
[Musik]
also leute ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
es ist lustig für ein video
aber im endeffekt ist das viel mehr
sauerei als dass es dir irgendwie weiter
hilft also ich finde dass es total
umständlich da mache ich dann doch
lieber mit messer deswegen würde ich
hier sagen lustig aber auf jeden fall
durchgefallen
das funktioniert nicht so gut wie es im
video aussieht noch heute das tut das
toastbrot man sieht ja auch kaum butter
drauf dass er sowohl wie nix drauf und
guck dir mal den an wie der aussieht und
jetzt guckt ihr noch meine hände an die
aussehen und dann guckt ihr noch die
butter an wie die aussieht
ja gut dann passieren wie sieht aus wie
meine ex okay leute passt auch und zwar
das hier ist der dritte live sondern
danach noch in firmen oder den über
einen nächsten verschieben weil wir
haben jetzt ja schon ziemlich lange
braucht für die oder ok ich hab jetzt
hier einen teller glas und wer kennt es
nicht das ist nutella glas jetzt zum
beispiel da ist noch ein ziemlich kühl
treffen kann man sehen
ich habe mir gedacht das ist vielleicht
gar nicht so schlecht da ein bisschen
mehr tun zu haben weil dann willst du
noch leckerer wir schauen uns jetzt den
nächsten live kann eigentlich mein
lieblings live-act vielleicht auch weil
ich so einen großen teller fallen bin
also habe ich eigentlich jeden tag und
vergessen ist jetzt ein bisschen weniger
geworden ist also das mit den masters
muss ich jetzt vielleicht nicht machen
aber wir können ja mal versuchen ob wir
hier von dann heiße schokolade
hinkriegen die lecker ist als erstes
milch in den topf
das sollte eigentlich auch schon reichen
weil das nutella glas hat halt auch nur
250 gramm glaube ich oder so das ist
jetzt gate array milch milch blau werden
haben eigentlich wir haben jetzt alle
mittel wir könnten jetzt ja noch die
milch blau macht dann in den lippenstift
sein und dann auf toastbrot mit reifen
und dann noch 50 euro schein glatten
übrigens sollte falls ihr noch nicht
abonniert haben abonniert auf jeden fall
den kanal weil dann sind wir bald einen
moment da war doch was wären wir von
einigen
aber man kann natürlich trotzdem den
kanal abonnieren weil sind schon eine
million 6000 glaube ich aber dann seid
ihr bald zwei millionen million 494.000
jetzt aber schnell erreicht er dann auch
schon
dann machen wir das mal wieder aus so
jetzt hab ich das mal ganz vorsichtig
reinigen wie sieht das
[Musik]
ja okay ich habe glas verbrennen gleich
ne yo das ist jetzt passiert es zu heiß
das trifft trifft überall raus leute
hier muss man extrem aufpassen das glas
ist sehr sehr heiß sieht jetzt schon
wieder aus wie sau bereich
ich hätte es natürlich mega cool
gefunden wenn dadurch jetzt diese
übrigen teile automatisch praktisch vom
vom rand verschwindet aber das ist
leider nicht der fall also zumindest
nicht so gut gemeint sieht das
eigentlich wieder aus wie ein ganz neues
nutella glas aber jetzt ist ja von der
seite ab gegangen wenn du es richtig
schüttelt naja vielleicht war hier ist
noch ein bisschen zu viel mit da drin
das kann natürlich sein kann man den
deckel an sich abgelöst
halter also man sieht auf jeden fall ist
deutlich dunkler aus als im video aber
ich muss auch sagen im video von wilisch
da war es vielleicht noch ein bisschen
zu hell ich könnte es natürlich noch ein
bisschen milch nach kippen soll ich das
machen oder nicht ich würde sagen ich
probiere das jetzt einfach mal so und
sagen euch ob es schmeckt das mit den
marshmallows sparen wir uns jetzt weil
die würde ich eh nicht essen das ist
dann halt nur fürs auge so
also ich möchte schon jetzt richtig gut
also mac brutal nach und teller
natürlich ein bisschen weniger herz
aufgetan
aber es ist sehr sehr heiß wird ist
geradezu ein richtiges leuchten in den
augen
irgendwie schmeckt das gut weil ich
meine dicke das richtig obwohl alter
aber da ich glaube das ist so ungesund
überlebt man werde jetzt halt eigentlich
sei ja nur ein hotel drin so als wenn er
mit einem seiner hand einmal durchgehen
geil also das ist das beste heute kein
fake 10 von 10 punkten slacker empfehle
ich euch macht es auf jeden fall auch
mal zu hause nach stell dir vor du
machst in wales dein tor
das wäre doch eigentlich auch was für so
ein stehen so etwas zu machen oder wir
haben ja noch meine löw hätte dann würde
ich sagen das war heiss heute drei live
hacks das video geht wahrscheinlich
schon ziemlich lange eigentlich wollte
ich viel machen der vierte ist aber sehr
aufwendig ich glaube dann wird das es an
die 20 minuten gehen
deswegen würde ich ne in den nächsten
partien sollten uns vielleicht schon mal
kurz anspielen einmal zeigen derzeit
kein oder oder so was da noch machen
dann können wir das halt essen -
plötzlich essen willst du immer da ist
ok dann macht es beim nächsten video
leute wir gehen jetzt erst mal was essen
ich hatte eigentlich geplant das als
mein mittagessen heute zu nehmen aber
ich hoffe natürlich dass hat euch
gefallen dass nur nach oben da ncm alex
wie und haut weiter
[Musik]